bon rideaux baissés salles fermées
c'était aujourd'hui la grande journée de
mobilisation des intermittents du
spectacle de manifestations un peu
partout en france contre une remise en
cause de leur régime d'assurance chômage
un régime lourdement déficitaire céline
crespy frédéric dollar ils sont acteurs
techniciens du spectacle de
l'audiovisuel ou danseurs 15000 à
défiler ce soir à paris pour défendre
leur statut d'intermittent eu la chance
jamais avoir eu besoin d'être aidés par
les assedic mais je vois beaucoup de mes
camarades fort bon comédien qui
travaillent et qu'ils tiennent grâce à
ça ça ne doit pas mourir parce que de
toute manière c'est idiot on va rayer 50
60 % de ce métier car selon les
intermittents la nature même de leur
métier justifie une assurance chômage
plus avantageuse il ya tout le travail
qui est qui vous voyais pas quand on est
sur scène qui est derrière
il est beaucoup plus énorme c'est juste
la petite île truc visible d'un iceberg
ce que vous voyez il s'agit pas d'être
privilégié la plupart des intermittents
gagnent le smic théâtres fermés y
culture vent berne comme ici à toulouse
car la mobilisation est montée d'un cran
en pleine renégociation du régime des
intermittents jugé trop coûteux par le
medef le ministre lui même a été
interpellé lors de la dernière soirée
des césar il ya quelques jours jean
jacques aillagon dénonçait les abus
intermittence on ne met pas en cause
uniquement certains employés nous
mettons en cause également les
employeurs qui se servent de
l'intermittence comme d'une commodité de
gestion de leur relation avec leurs
employés
le conflit paraît dans l'impasse aucune
date n'a été arrêtée pour décider de
l'avenir du régime des intermittents